cuando estalló el movimiento de las
vidas negras importan por la muerte de
George Floyd en 2020 la respuesta social
fue más virulenta al tratarse de
policías blancos
tiene que ver No tanto con con la
situación de policías blanco sino la
brutalidad de policía
desgraciadamente o desafortunadamente en
este momento fueron cinco policías
negros pero es el mismo sistema de la
policía por tanto hay una escalada si me
permiten brevemente podemos decir por
ejemplo por por la estadística de de
según Washington post desde desde estos
últimos 12 meses aproximadamente
1.110
personas han sido asesinadas por tiros
de la policía estamos hablando de en
estos 12 meses quiere decir que
solamente en el 2022 hubo un momento de
la brutalidad policial
hablando o citando estas cifras que
usted menciona se puede hablar de
violencia policial sistemática en
Estados Unidos podemos hablar que hay
una violencia sistemática en la policía
de Estados Unidos que va en aumento
vamos a analizar de manera breve cuando
el asesinato de George Floyd se se lanzó
una legislación
en el senado Y todavía estamos en 2023 y
todavía no se ha logrado Avance en esa
legislación una legislación que nos
permite a nosotros los ciudadanos por lo
menos liberarnos un poquito un poquito
más de esa violencia de policía donde
policía tiene que reportar donde Por
ejemplo si un policía ve a otro cometer
una infracción o una brutalidad tener la
oportunidad de corregirlo y demandarlo
en el caso de taylon fueron a los
extremos estamos hablando que solamente
en cuatro minutos
en cuatro minutos copiaron nueve nueve
veces o sea menos de cuatro minutos
copiaron nueve meses a tylon o sea
estamos hablando de de un extremo
ahora existe un estigma incluso de
policías negros hacia gente de clase
trabajadora afro la cuestión racial
también está atravesada por la clase
cree usted
Yo diría que
cuando bueno analizando de punto de
vista como defensor de derechos humanos
y cuando se entra a un sector
como el de la policía dentro de la misma
policía sabemos que hay hay un racismo
sistemático pero a la misma vez el mismo
sistema lo lo involucra y los hace
cometer este este acto la pregunta que
todos no hacemos y todo se hacen o que
todos los comentarios dices Bueno pero
fueron cinco policías negros no fueron
blancos está bien
Pero el punto está que el sistema
policial de manera sistemática entrena
prepara y psicológicamente prepara a
policía para autodestruir y no y no
defender no estoy generalizando que toda
la policía es así pero la mayoría de de
de las pruebas que nos dan sucede así ya
uno no sabe con este acontecimiento
Cuando uno sale si uno regresa vivo a la
casa si los hijos de uno regresan vivo a
la casa uno no puede llamar al 911
porque en vez de llamar al 911 uno se
convierte en víctima la arbitrariedad
que sucedió ahora con Taylor es
inaceptable por eso la gente está en las
calles y está en las calles porque no
hay solución